c'erano la foresta un uomo gay una donna
del sud due uomini etero pianti chi
spende che per facilitarci chiameremo lo
stronzo e la vispa teresa un avvocato
non
biodegradabile una ragazza che non aveva
più nulla da perdere un poveretto in
cerca di fama giulia pacciani savastano
mostro di firenze gomorra e di manuale
l'autista col cambio manuale napoli
sorge all'interno di un contesto
geografico mozzafiato
accostabile solamente al giardino
dell'eden città di
tradizione e sapori storia magia e
divertimento
napoli è un miracolo fatto
architettura colori profumi e suoni dal
sussurro del mare al rombo del vesuvio
fino alle urla di mercati capaci di
lacerarsi il timpano irrimediabilmente
in una lingua ignota che poi è quella di
gomorra solo che non ai sottotitoli si
dice che se vai a napoli piange due
volte quando arrivi e quando parti ma
anche quando ti metti in macchina e la
gente ti lancia le pietre addosso per a
certi fermato rosso o quando una donna
dei venti loro timori dice mentre circa
di menardi numeri del lotto con quando
provi il brivido del ritrovare la tua
macchina senza la marmitta o quando
gridi i poster pubblicitari della
comunione di una bambina dove sotto
orgoglio di mamme papà cucciolotta c'è
la foto di una decenne vestita da sposa
o quando un parcheggiatore bomba beh
avete capito insomma in conclusione
napoli e
cappelli pizza uopi mozzarella
sfogliatelle babà ma soprattutto tanto
tanto che a vis con i signori signori
solo per voi
napoli
e gli occhi su un caffé
ve napoletano
ragazzi questa qui era una tappa che non
vedevo l'ora di fare la mia pancia non
vedeva l'ora di fa anche i miei occhi ci
troviamo a napoli zona castel sant'elmo
e qui potete vederla nella sua bellezza
a napoli è fatta di contrasti dicotomie
calda e fredda perché qua ci stiamo a
cacasotto dal freddo non mi hanno detto
che sotto invece fa caldo è una donna
che sa essere argini e tutta napoli
napoli
[Musica]
domanda voli mezz'ora vario altro che
giocherà un ora e mezza dal parcheggio e
terapie
rabizzi maria ad una vera pizza
ma come ti sei conciata manco per il
cappuccio amici napoletani campagna
generalità in macchina graziana che
dinho c'era ha iniziato a parlare con
accento napoletano non si sentiva certo
centro messo a mi ha detto guarda che si
parli così ti sparano chiede sparerei e
ho capito ma se sto parlando napoletano
[Musica]
sbirciando maiali in mezzo alla strada
io sono qui con due dei maggiori
esponenti del movimento napoli è
bellissima ma abbiamo fame ho fame
vogliamo sfondarsi una pizza portafoglio
ma a loro tutti non a farci girare per
napoli con i serpenti voglio che la mia
lingua mi faccio sapere dove sono fateci
mangiare
vi prego guardatemi commissionate ferita
ci troviamo davanti alla fontana dei
giganti e la quale si possono esprimere
dei desideri ed è transennata quindi non
possiamo esprimere desideri ma sono di
buon auspicio che ci sia la trans
assolutamente no firenze il maiale che
non entravano e monetine quale la
fontana senza decidere questa spinta di
positività continuiamo la nota che tra
poco mangiamo napoli è veramente grande
e ragazzi per cui io chiedo già scusa
sarà impossibile far vedere tutti i
punti più belli per chi non è milano è
uno tsunami posti assurdi faremo del
nostro meglio col frustino starò lì a
farci galoppare oggi sono stato travolto
dai andiamo andiamo io comunque
desiderio danno a mangiarlo esprimo
comunque
[Musica]
siamo a piazza entry riuscito anziana ci
sta lanciando una sfida che a quanto
pare un qualcosa di famoso qui a napoli
la regina margherita ai carcerati una
volta mese e concedeva la possibilità di
sperimentare questa prova e se
riuscivano ad attraversare e ad arrivare
fino ai due canali senza perdere della
direzione avevano salva la vita
è un bagno di sangue in questa storia se
io ci riesco mi prendo un mese di ferie
andata di forza
ma scusami e sono qui per un altro
motivo la vigna in cerca del marito
napoletano va bene non volevo dirlo
fatti sta cercando il papà di carne per
cancro che l'impedimento dell'albero non
è da sottovalutare però una volta che
arrivi all'albero lo circa un navighi
ceo suggerire chiana
[Musica]
non ho idea di dove sono perso
l'orientamento
[Musica]
mai mai
[Risate]
[Musica]
ho fatto mai top
levati la maschera
un mese liberia
[Musica]
ogni anno nella piazza centrale è lì con
l'albero dei desideri ogni bambino anche
agli adulti attacca un desiderio a
cantare giganti i desideri non te li
fanno esprimere qui l'albero dei
desideri c'è manco la preside e comunque
ho visto che grazie ha detto che i
bambini esprimere desideri il mio
desiderio rimane sempre di andare a
mangiare prima quello ormai già
quarant'anni di pregio che andiamo in
magnate pomeriggio la pizza questa sera
ce l'abbiamo corrisponda a cena certo
non
marco marco
andiamo enrico
enrico enrico forse le vetrate sono più
belle a milano ma gli archi qui come
architettura insomma me sono molto più
figli che tu vai su youtube eroe youtube
e senza youtubers non sarebbe youtube
senza gli antimafiosi no non è vero è
molto simpatica
se bebop xvi gesù volte lui monta beni
video i ragazzi
[Musica]
risiedere stato espresso il mio
desiderio è stato espresso si dice
esaudito è mio desiderio è stato
esaudito
no
a napoli sono di una gentilezza magna ha
detto rosa
gentile e
ammette proprio è stanno qui per un
altro motivo più buona
drammatico fare
finalmente
addirittura l'idea di cos'è sta roba
sono molto triste che non ho la foglia
di basilico troppo carino
ma anche usare sono troppo impegnato a
mangiare scusate se non ve lo dico buona
la donna va dai boccone o che sono
questi i cuochi dove il mostro di
firenze ceco morra
assaggiatelo spaccanapoli lega che
qualcosa di allucinante
no se vede che è troppo buono
forse oggi vedremo la vita te la metà
dei monumenti che volevamo vedere credo
che nessun napoletano si incazzerà se vi
diciamo che questi suoi monumenti che
abbiamo visto ma abbiamo como viene a
napoli piange tre volte quando arriva
quando generale quando cassano d
altronde anni draghi con il miur food
che abbiamo fatto cioè proprio le altre
città prese hafiz la gentilezza la
simpatia alla teatralità proprio i
napoletani battono di vento era l'italia
in ginocchio di fronte allo street food
di napoletano di tali ginocchio davanti
a napolitano io sono pieno ma non riesco
a fermarmi dice marina che a breve
iniziera
dagli occhiali da sole ed è buio
dobbiamo ancora girare la città
praticamente non so chi ma 104 100 ma ti
rifai una sfogliatella tra dieci metri
sempre acque della iii e poi sappiamo e
cantare poi comincia quella degli dito
devo vedere questa città dove siamo
tutti i numeri voglio san gregorio
armeno che si sta dio mitra sfondare il
tema mano anche una vita portafoglio
oltre a tutto il meglio di napoletani
sono stati sempre sorridente carini
imparare a julian è stato ha sudato olio
di frittura proprio
r il posto
è
sandra milo più
[Applauso]
il marito di madonna mia
ma la storia di una madre di tutte le
città a napoli
sto godendo è più buono di quello che
pensassi
addirittura in due morti cioè io ero
foto con tre non ci sto chiedendo che è
arrivato sono arrivati altri
cosi
cose sono due o mica dugnano adesso o
mai più c'è un caos non smettiamo di
mangiare cammina non voltarti indietro
se vedo un altro napoletano con un
sacchetto che ci si avvicina
[Musica]
addetto alla produzione ea quello che
batte i tempi oggi sono stato travolto
notte non abbiamo visto un cazzo ma
anche un caffè abbiamo visto le donne
napoletane sono veramente veramente
belle qualcuna se lo pigli cioè statista
cosa dall'inizio di quando siamo
arrivati non lo sopportiamo più
napoletane quelle bolognesi quello
dettato a quelle romane fu scatto dalla
pagina questo ragazzo troppo giovane per
ogni potesse portiamo per mostre firenze
nostre carte di credito tremano giulia
stai giulia sta andando a comprare dei
taralli mettendo il posto montagna da
dove tutti i tarallini utili in alto
anche ne mangio
addio di raiola ha una missione la madre
della fidanzata di nostro fratello gian
luigi mi ha chiesto due colori per il
presepe che ha un personaggio di 40
centimetri della mamma che la madre
che deve portare rigon non tu a tua
madre due pecore perché ha chiesto a lui
no
mai
via
[Musica]
sul mare
non ho mai visto niente di più bello il
numero e scozzesi un po mi inquietano
sono tutte le cose spirito 13 fotografie
esclusive irripetibili della padania
vista dai napoletani
festa della befana in padania
particolare i bambini che giocano con i
balocchi sotto un manto di stelle
temo che gli juventini non siano molto
graditi creato un tool che squadra tifi
adesso siamo a san gregorio armeno è il
cuore pulsante del presepe napoletano la
genialità fino a dove arriva
[Musica]
proprio dalla corretta della vita
è il dottor rosario è il mio giarda
[Musica]
napoli ragazzi è stupenda credo che sia
alla città ad un più soste nella nella
vita io sono strafatto di carboidrati o
praticamente il fritto che mi scorre
nelle vene ho bisogno di un centro di
recupero per mangiatori anonimi ciao sto
a napoli e sono dieci minuti che non
mangio
ogni metri ci fermiamo senza una
motivazione valida enrico se scelto ai
parenti no tutti i tipi di pecore ma
erano o troppo grandi o troppo piccole
il problema della pecora è difficile
trovare quella pro tempore faccia per
terra il presepe basta che ci sta il bue
e l'asinello capito scusate
[Musica]
mamma mia è veramente un momento super
super romantico le palle mosce proprio a
terra
[Musica]
un punto
siamo a cena fuori
non vorrei che in campo
ciao pietro ti senti stiamo per
sfondarsi come sempre di roba tipica
napoletana ma sotto la mia supervisione
godia la visione verso la tua custodia
hagrid modo per dire se il piatto che
assaggiano euro
io lo dico perché non partecipino
dopo mangeremo forza che ai pomodorini
del piennolo
tipico con uno striscione le falde
dell'etna
16 st dal paesaggio di morte per chi ai
13 anni
siamo 13 ok è il modo migliore è milano
14 st una persona per l'amore detti
anche punto stai perché siamo inseriti
sia favola io capisco il compleanno il
tuo padre siamo 13 essendo 13 al tavolo
una persona dentro sette giorni morirà
per il mio e anche mangiando anche
attivato per i quali sia il predatore e
leon cino non si ma non si prenderà o si
regala peroncino prima o perché loro mi
hanno fatto di paglia
riforme
[Musica]
ed è così che questa puntata del global
finisce qui tra fritti sogna e altri
grassi saturi ingerite per voi che avete
avuto le palle di resistere fino a
questo punto grazie ragazzi avete
stomaco da vendere ritardo il fico il
bicchiere un po gli occhi ma il
bicchiere dove che rinvigorente
ho capito ma non è la pasta della non
erano
due ragazzi questa è la pasta al mira lo
è una pasta con zucchine fritte
dibattito io ha portato a spazio per
napoli è stato di caserta
ed è stato bellissimo concludere questa
giornata natalizia napoli con
degli amici della della vita veronica e
lauro e gerardo
adesso però uscite scopate divertitevi e
se vi va nome nei fatti kitambo natale
un cazzo
prossimo video